everything was uncertain and i'm just
like the ones
even the show happening i had to stop
doing that
and just get confident and say this is
happening they say it's still happening
what's it like sitting here right now in
this space
it feels so good which after
five months of everyone being so
forced to be uncomfortable and
re-evaluate everything
and in some ways
have a real rebirth the thing that is
the most
important to know in these times is you
don't need a
and b scenario you need a b and c
scenario
do you want to shoot this in another
state do you want to do this from home
we're going to
not be in a studio we're going to be in
a loft somewhere
you'll not have a crew you won't have an
audience
we kept hearing every single week
a new revelation of what the pandemic
uh was narrowing down in our options
so with no options how can you believe
in opportunity but we never gave up
we did not give in even if we have to do
this entire show virtually it should
look like
an expensive like cbs
juggernaut show of like i virtually want
to be there
oh my god
but we have something else to show you
that we were thinking about so this is
sort of an adaptation of what we were
doing last time that we loved
but we were thinking what if the
background is an led screen
and then we can bring in that oh my god
if it's an led screen
we can like soften the background and we
can move things we don't like
rain and we can make it we could sort of
you know we can do whatever we want back
there eventually
well i think that's what they call a
drop the mic moment
well you know again like we still have a
lot of a lot we still have a lot of
figuring out to do
and then certainly had a lot of things i
did want and i did love and i did want
to take with me
but every single thing that we've dealt
with in our path
has been this incredible learning curve
of how we wouldn't do it
and when you figure out how you wouldn't
do something
that is when the light bulb goes on
oh wow
oh my god
hi really nice to dance
it's so beautiful this is so amazing
it's been a little tough as far as
getting things in here but
just a couple curveballs i'm drew thank
you so much for
doing this i'm just trying to figure it
out and i want to do it with everybody
because it's much more fun that way
but i am a student and i don't know
things and i don't
pretend to know things i am learning and
i want to
learn with people then this is out
of a very insane production design movie
this is like minority report
how are you is it okay if i
absolutely yes okay so we just cover we
just cover the floor
and all these
[Laughter]
and so the technological advancement
that we really focused on
was something that gave me a new
outlook on my own professionalism
because i am very bohemian and old
school and i am not technological and i
am very much a girl
but this moment has made me
become someone that i never thought i
could be
let alone would be which is someone who
sought out every technological
advancement i just want to be
super proactive i know the holographic
like thing is not sustainable for a show
but i feel like
there are times we might want to choose
that battle
hi corona team how's it going in our new
normal oh
good tell me who you are and what you do
i'm drew
and we have a new show coming and here
we are to shoot promos for it
yeah big three marker
we're gonna figure out every single
modern technology
that we can use to not just the show's
advantage
but to modernize television please
welcome drew barrymore
i've been waiting all my life to meet
you it's been a wild ride can you
believe i have two daughters around your
age
kind of scary i have so much to fill you
in on wanna hear about our new daytime
show
love to we're gonna spend an hour every
day celebrating life
oh i'm so excited i could scream
wanna do it with me guys ready
i have so much work every single day
to figure out and reinvent and re-spark
that fire
and just get down to what is worth being
on the air
what are people going to respond to and
yet
you cannot think anyone's watching
so why do you do what you do
if you are not doing it thinking about
what other people think
[Music]
as hard as it is at least we don't have
the luxury
or ability to turn away from this we
actually get to be smarter and better
people by learning through this process
george floyd tony mcdade nina pop and so
many
you know how have we acknowledged that
this is in fact unfair
and that it hurts all of us it hurts our
communities
there are a lot of things happening
right now
um a lot of anxieties if you will
with the race conversation with
coronavirus
i really feel like especially when we're
doing african-american children's books
i love my history i'm working on two
historical books
right now all this comedy that i wanted
to do
is not appropriate anymore and i just
went off social media and i just
started writing and i got really quiet i
just felt like nobody's voice was really
appropriate and
same thing with black lives matter it
was just a
everybody has to be incredibly quiet and
respectful and this is not a time to
really talk about anything but the
subject
in front of you and so through
the making of this show we have been
continually tested on
given times in these crisis
and in these moments and in our culture
where it is time to
stop talking and start listening and
when you're doing a talk show
that can be very confusing inside
but i'm glad that this has been there
because it has given me a constant north
star of
how to find my voice in the most
respectful way
and i do think about what i say and how
i say it but ever more so
is that so crucial and
we always will find our way to comedy
that's the thing
because we need it comedy is not
frivolous comedy is
a medicinal drug-like thing
that we need i have to demote all of my
family members you're like my best
friend now
i think it might be one of the most
transportive
things we have as human beings
when i'm laughing
maybe for that second everything will be
okay maybe it's as simple as that but
that's very powerful
at the same time and maybe it just makes
me know
you know what there's good stuff here
it's all gonna be okay i guess comedy
just makes me feel like it's all gonna
be okay